[Music]
hulu's newest marvel show is a different
breed than what comic fans have been
watching on disney plus
putting the focus on a very unlikely
leading man modoc the marvel comics
references come as fast as the jokes in
modoc and it's hard to catch them all
here's a look at all the easter eggs you
may have missed
we see aim scientist supreme monica
rappuccini's daughter carmilla black in
a couple of scenes throughout the season
mostly interacting with modoc's son
lou anyone unfamiliar with the character
would be forgiven for not paying the
design of her outfit much attention as
it goes with her goth attire but her
white scorpion is a hint to her future
comics persona
in the comics monica messed with her
daughter's genetic makeup which becomes
apparent to the teenager when her toxin
powers manifest and cause carmilla to
kill her boyfriend
at their prom she takes up the name
scorpion and looks to avenge the people
she believed to be her parents
working for both sides and even being
sent to track down her own mother at one
point it's an interesting relationship
to say the least
save me joy division early in the season
modoc sets out to find his time machine
but we learned that it was actually
monica who built it the device or at
least the celestial chrono crystal that
powers it
becomes a huge part of the show's plot
at some point the device was apparently
confiscated by shield which means modok
must break onto a helicarrier to
retrieve the time machine in an effort
to save his relationship
one not so clever disguise later and
modoc is looking through boxes in a
shield storage locker finding all sorts
of nifty things from across the marvel
universe
fans of the x-men movies probably perked
up at the mention of the cerebro but
modok pulling out the ultimate nullifier
is a great little easter egg for die
hard marvel comics fans
it was used by the fantastic four to
convince galactus not to mess with earth
so it's pretty important which is why
modok's casual dismissal of it is so
perfect episode 4 has modoc form a team
for a heist but first they have to
retrieve team member 10 pins exploding
pins which takes the crew to the always
darkest before the pawn
pawn shop it's a great setup for
spotting familiar items from the marvel
universe like ant-man's helmet the real
treat in this shop however is all of the
x-men memorabilia the nightcrawler
plushie behind the counter is cute and
easy enough to spot but keynite viewers
will also notice that the mask on the
counter belongs to a hellfire club
soldier
magic soul sword mounted on the wall and
dazzler's silver skates from her
performing days
fenfang fume is a bit of a silly
character in the eyes of most fans but
he's also one that's been around for
quite a long time
a product of the 1960s he debuted in
strange tales number 89.
this shape-shifting alien's most widely
known form resembles that of a chinese
dragon
helping him on a mission to conquer
earth in modoc austin takes modak to a
restaurant called
finfeng farm to table where he cooks the
food with his fire breath
this may seem like a simple joke using
his name and dragon like abilities but
it's also a reference to a comic story
in 2005's
fenfang 4 where fume reforms and becomes
a chef
working inside the fantastic four's
baxter building in another episode modok
has a dream about flying on foom and
cheering
looking down at his utopian city this is
a reference to 1984's the never-ending
story and it's a moment that will stir
some major nostalgia for people who grew
up with it
at least until modoc's dream ends
abruptly and we see the state his life
is in
even modoc loves to socialize and drink
with his fellow villainous scum but the
big names aren't down for partying with
him this brings him to the bar with no
name
a joint that has become rather infamous
in the comics not just because of its
clientele but for the violence that
tends to occur there
usually this particular haven acts as a
safe spot but that doesn't always work
out for the version viewers are shown in
modoc we get quite the array of b-list
villain guest stars armadillo melter
angar the screamer pound cakes and
10-pin all play into the plot while
whirlwind makes an appearance and orb
acts as the bartender it's an amusing
introduction to a list of usually
forgettable characters whose hijinks
eventually lead the audience to also see
mandrill and much more of him than most
probably wanted to
the thing is a founding member of the
fantastic four and someone who has
helped save the world his fair share of
times but many out there feel old ben
grimm
has never truly received the respect he
deserves modok only gives him the
smallest of nods with his fist appearing
as part of a commercial
advertising alcohol with wolverine's
distinctive claw but if you look closely
the thing also gets one other brief nod
when modok and his group are riding the
subway some graffiti plastered above
them reads yancy street gang rules
this is a reference to a local group
from ben's old neighborhood who are not
necessarily criminals but more
mischief makers and serial harassers who
have it out for the thing
david cannon is a mutant super villain
better known as whirlwind he pops up a
couple of times in modoc wearing all
green armor with saw blades but he
doesn't have much to do with the overall
narrative
there is however a fun reference to the
character's comics origin
just before melissa modoc's daughter
wrenches whirlwind's arm and slams his
face onto the bar he's trying to
congratulate her on a great triple axel
she pulled off
hey congrats on that triple axel i get a
real pleasure out of watching you skank
formerly known as the human top
whirlwind was also a figure skater at
one point
back when his criminal exploits were
just beginning to blossom
modoc is full of guest stars fun cameos
and brief sightings that aren't
necessarily hard to spot but not all of
these are exactly well-known characters
even for fans of the comics
they're saying you're not a top-tier
super villain when wonder man shows up
to handle tattered demelian he's at
least
identified by name but that isn't true
for a lot of the others
hip-hop a literal cyborg kangaroo is
seen on a billboard but at least his
name is visible if anyone wants to look
him up and see if he's a real character
that time has forgotten
which he is a few more cameos come in a
scene when modoc is going through a list
of various portal dimensions
showing the scrolls one of the shiar
that looks a lot like lalondra
a watcher and the brood who makes an
appearance later in the episode but what
about mr waffles the bunny a character
from the 40s better known as super
rabbit
that's definitely a weird and well
hidden reference there's also a brief
scene with a demonic talk show host
named master pandemonium who
inexplicably has two baby demons for
hands hardcore fans will know that those
weird hands are definitely from the
comics and it's creepy to see them no
matter what
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
marvel comics movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one